[Musique]
on veut étudier sur cinq à dix ans les
impacts du changement climatique sur les
milieux profond c'est pour ça qu'on met
cet observatoire marin on pourrait
encore on peut imaginer que cet
observatoire marin c'est l'équivalent de
ce qui est fait sur mars est
actuellement avec persévérance bâti
botte c'est le persévérance du domaine
profond
[Musique]
on a une caméra haute sensibilité et
haute définition qui permet de faire de
la de filmer les espèces bioluminescente
dans l'obscurité totale
[Musique]
ce récif artificiel va aussi pouvoir
permettre à des bactéries
bioluminescente de d'entrer en contact
et donc d'émettre un flash lumineux et
donc de pouvoir mieux comprendre de
quelle manière elles vivent puisqu'on
connaît très mal les grands fonds
[Musique]